An instant hit or a swing and a miss?
The critics have spoken, and not all of them
are in love with "Peacemaker."
Here's what they're saying.
Reviews for the James Gunn series "Peacemaker"
have started to trickle in ahead of its January
13th debut on HBO Max, and much like its titular
antihero, there's apparently a lot to like
— and abhor — about the "The Suicide Squad"
spin-off.
Alan Sepinwall wrote in his review for Rolling
Stone:
"Even in a wildly oversaturated market for
tales of hypermuscular men and women punching
their way to justice, Peacemaker stands out.
You'll wanna taste it, even the parts that
are in incredibly bad taste."
He also called the show a "gloriously goofy
sendup and a sincere character study rolled
into one."
Last time viewers saw John Cena's Peacemaker
aka Chris Smith, he was walking the line between
DC Comics hero and full-blown villainy after
taking the life of Joel Kinnaman's Rick Flag
in the final act of Gunn's "The Suicide Squad."
In "Peacemaker," the babbling brute is back
and on a new mission per the orders of Amanda
Waller, but there are a few things different
about him.
We learn more about his backstory and get
to know the character on a more personal and
emotional level, much to some viewers' dismay.
As Carly Lane wrote for Collider:
"Peacemaker is definitely a less bombastic
series, dealing more in relationships than
action overall.
But it might have also proven more successful
if it wasn't so focused on trying to render
its lead more of a likable douchebag."
Here's what else critics are saying so far
about the series, which as of the making of
this video currently holds around a 90% score
on Rotten Tomatoes.
So far, the overall consensus from critics
on "Peacemaker" has been positive.
But in each review, there's been one constant
critique: not enough action or edginess — most
especially, from Peacemaker.
Angie Han wrote for The Hollywood Reporter:
"Peacemaker loses too much of the darkness
that made him compelling in the first place.
[James Gunn] makes the character more likable,
at the cost of making him less interesting."
Collider's Carly Lane agreed, saying:
"What makes Peacemaker such an interesting
and compelling character is his unrepentant
awfulness, and the series choosing to back-pedal
on what could be considered his defining traits
only makes for an aggressively fine follow-up."
When it comes to the action in "Peacemaker,"
it's obvious that Gunn didn't have as much
to work with financially as he did making
"The Suicide Squad."
Fred Topel from the United Press International
wrote,
"The Peacemaker series feels mostly like the
Suicide Squad comedy scenes without the big
action of a $100 million studio blockbuster.
[...] Fight scenes are not as clear or epic
as The CW pulls off weekly in several superhero
shows.
However, on HBO Max, the fights are punctuated
by the absurd violence that computer generated
visual effects allows."
In spite of all this, critics ultimately believe
there's enough creative meat on the "Peacemaker"
bone to leave viewers satisfied for an entire
season.
When it comes down to it, James Gunn's "Peacemaker"
isn't supposed to be a show that's perfect.
And that's what makes it so perfect for some.
The Daily Beast's Nick Shager said:
"Self-conscious but never smug, sociopathic
and yet also sweet, and timely if never preachy,
it's the very sort of no-holds-barred, tongue-in-cheek
endeavor that's become Gunn's specialty."
Alan Sepinwall explained in Rolling Stone's
review:.
"Between the blood and guts, the slapstick,
the political satire ... and the musical digressions
... there is a lot going on here.
Yet the series functions as a sincere character
study of its flawed hero — and the unfortunate
souls who have to work alongside him — just
enough for the joke to never quite wear thin."
As for some of the biggest highlights for
Gunn's new series, critics have propped up
its character dynamics, opening credits sequences
and numerous appearances by Peacemaker's pet
eagle as perfect examples of the director's
over-the-top, yet satisfying, vision.
Speaking specifically about the intro, Sepinwall
said:
"It is essentially an Eighties-style music
video.
[...] It's the kind of inspired gag that makes
a mockery of the Skip Intro option, remaining
a delight every single time it comes up.
But then, the same could be said for ol' bucket-headed
Peacemaker himself."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.